[Applause]
I think today you know why I'm happy now
for Ida 4:20 I know you you know what
that means your taxes are five days late
stoners did you sign that check on April
15th lo even when there's a good
president in the White House that is a
painful check it's a sign when it's it's
really tough when you know it's going to
redecorate Scott Pruitt's office that's
I wrote on the memo on on my check
dining room table for Ben Carson have
you read about this [ __ ] guidance
scott pruett this APA had maybe the most
corrupt official ever in a cabinet and
now he wants to change I love this the
logo of the EPA the Environmental
Protection Agency - a picture of a
buffalo and a Bible verse because
nothing says environmental protection
like a picture of an animal we almost
drove to extinction and a book that
doesn't believe in science that's
so let's see what's going on on season
two of The Apprentice White House
edition the big villain of the week this
week for a Donald Trump is Jim Comey
former FBI director Comey because he's
out there selling a book boy he's on
more TV shows than Mike 11 Eddie no but
I said Jim Comey was on dr. oz this
morning she just going dr. oz where
Trump touched him with dolls I mean
[Laughter]
and Trump as a new lawyer you heard this
rudy giuliani from the law firm of
Jacobi and Dracula hey Rudy got famous
by attaching himself to a pile of rubble
it could work again you know
well first Trump goes to Washington now
Giuliani congratulations in New York is
slowly getting rid of your rat problem
that wasn't the guy he was really
sweating it out these days is Michael
Cohen Michael Cohen from criminal lawyer
and when I say criminal lawyer I mean a
lawyer who's a criminal which looks like
his meetings take place on a park bench
and every consultation ends with the
words this never happened it's he's the
one who famously said I take a bullet
for Donald Trump well nowadays looking
at prison time we'll see if he's willing
to take a dick
it was something positive this week
congratulations to Kendrick Lamar you
heard what happened there the the first
rapper to win one of the world's most
prestigious prizes the bathroom code at
Starbucks
[Applause]
yes that's in support of what we live
[ __ ] liberals get Jordan Peterson out
here right now I get it [ __ ] kick
some asses no you heard about what
happened at the Starbucks in
Philadelphia they ordered two blacks to
go
[Applause]
yes what happened was two
african-american gentlemen rich
Starbucks meeting a white guy waiting on
him that's the first interesting thing
here the white guy was running late and
apparently waiting while black is not
allowed at this Starbucks oh the
authorities were called and it made
national news when the cops showed up
because they they didn't shoot them what
kind of criminals hang out at Starbucks
I mean aside from Michael : I mean these
guys spent 20 minutes listening to Lana
Del Ray isn't that punishment enough